bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir est
avocat il revient de Genève où il a
plaidé contre Tariq Ramadan accusé de
viols bonsoir Françoise et merci
beaucoup d'être là vous défendiez la
plaignante contre l'islamologue que la
justice suisse a donc acquitté au
bénéfice du doute on va y revenir
longuement vous faites appel audience
ultra médiatisée caricatural avez-vous
écrit vous allez nous dire pourquoi la
parole de votre cliente n'a pas été
selon vous respectez on reviendra aussi
sur votre parcours vous êtes un grand
défenseur des droits de l'homme ancien
ambassadeur de France au Danemark on en
parle ensemble tout à l'heure mais on
commence ce soir avec cette question à
la fois morale stratégique et politique
comment combattre efficacement le
rassemblement national cette question
s'est invitée au sommet de l'état d'un
côté Elisabeth borne attaque Marine Le
Pen sur l'héritage pétainiste de son
parti de l'autre Emmanuel Macron recadre
sa première ministre en affirmant qu'on
ne peut plus combattre le RN avec des
arguments moraux alors qui a raison qui
a tort faut-il accepter la normalisation
du RN grand débat dans un instant avec
mes invités sur ce plateau avant de
retrouver 20h15 les affranchis leur
parti pris et puis Bourbon Express bien
sûr l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
voilà pour le programme ce soir vous me
suivez Françoise ça vous regarde c'est
parti
[Musique]
c'est une polémique de plus qui la
replace au centre du jeu Marine Le Pen
et bien cette invité à sa manière dans
le huis clos du Conseil des ministres ce
mercredi le recadrage de la première
ministre par le président révèle la
fébrilité au sommet de l'État sur le RN
Macron Bordes un même adversaire mais
deux méthodes pour le combattre bonsoir
François-Xavier bourneau et merci d'être
là vous êtes grand reporter au service
politique du Figaro chargé du suivi de
l'Élysée de Matignon et de la majorité
donc parfaitement à même de nous
éclairer sur ce débat vous retrouver
votre compère complice Charles sapin
bonsoir journaliste au Point en charge
du suivi du rassemblement national mais
pas seulement aussi des populismes en
Europe et tous les deux vous êtes les
auteurs de ce livre Macron Le Pen le
tango des fossoyeurs c'était aux
éditions de l'archipel évidemment
particulièrement pertinent pour se débat
bonsoir Stéphane zumseg ravi de vous
retrouver directement de l'institut
Ipsos le RN est-il devenu un parti comme
les autres aux yeux des Français vous
allez nous le dire dans un instant enfin
bonsoir Jean-Philippe Moinet bonsoir
ravi de vous accueillir directeur de la
revue civique vous aviez fondé un
observatoire en son temps
pionniers à l'époque observatoire de
l'extrémisme François zimerais votre
regard évidemment nous intéresse dans ce
débat en tant qu'enseignant de France au
Danemark notamment un pays érigé en
modèle pour cette politique très ferme
sur l'immigration qui a fait chuter
l'extrême droite donc n'hésitez pas à
intervenir et à interroger nos invités
on commence par planter le décor la
polémique et que révèle il a 200
secondes c'est le chrono de la côte tout
de suite
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
Monsieur puisque vous êtes la seule
femme ce soir Stéphane Blacko
c'est normal autant commencer par
l'attitude donc cette fameuse polémique
un peu à deux balles selon moi dans Le
Parisien je vous laisse le découvrir si
vous ne suivez pas toutes les polémiques
d'ailleurs le RN aurait le président
pardon aurait donc conditionnel selon
des témoins anonymes évidemment qui ne
se dénoncent pas recadrer la première
ministre tu parles d'une affaire en fait
il aurait reproché d'avoir rappelé que
le RN et l'héritier de Pétain alors que
sont selon lui c'est pas du tout la
bonne méthode pour lutter contre le
Front national mais je sais pas si vous
connaissez des journalistes l'idée de
lancer une petite polémique pour faire
monter l'audience qui sont jamais contre
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
réécouter ce qu'a dit Elisabeth borne on
écoute
c'est moi je vous crois pas du tout à la
normalisation du rassemblement national
je pense qu'il faut pas banaliser ses
idées ses idées sont toujours les mêmes
alors maintenant le rassemblement
national il met les formes mais je pense
continuer à penser que c'est une
idéologie dangereuse
oui également Éric Pétain alors ok elle
l'a dit enfin c'est pas franchement une
déclaration spontanée c'est surtout le
journaliste qui avait très très envie de
lui faire dire mais comment dire le
contraire puisque effectivement le Front
national à l'origine celui de Jean-Marie
Le Pen était un regroupement de
nostalgie du nazisme et de la
collaboration donc même si c'est vrai le
problème c'est que ça l'embarrasse pas
plus que ça Marine Le Pen ça fait 40 ans
qu'on lui rappelle et puis depuis 40 ans
ils sont partis ne cesse de grimper on
l'écoute le gouvernement prend une
stratégie un peu folle puisque elle
réitère toujours les mêmes
argumentations grossières ou transfert
insultante ça fait 40 ans que ça dure et
je crois pouvoir vous dire que ça a été
très peu efficace
donc ça c'est la position de Marine Le
Pen et quitte à vous surprendre et bien
Emmanuel Macron a exactement la même
position sur le sujet une fois qu'il a
chassé cette polémique en renouvelant sa
confiance à une lgbde ça lui a quand
même priori de préciser quel était selon
lui la meilleure méthode pour lutter
contre le RN dans l'écoute on ne peut
plus battre dans nos démocraties
l'extrême droite simplement avec des
arguments historiques et moraux d'abord
parce que c'est extrême droite s'est
transformé et ensuite parce qu'elle a
beaucoup d'électeurs aujourd'hui qui ne
votent pas pour cette histoire mais
votre parce qu'il se disent au fond on
n'a pas encore essayé cela et ce qui
nous propose par est séduisant
il faut répondre au concret
du concret bref ce que nous dit le
président c'est que depuis plusieurs
années de nombreuses années le RN
l'extrême droite prospère sur les échecs
des gouvernements successifs à la tête
du pays que si on veut le faire reculer
il faudrait obtenir des résultats
concrets c'est ce qu'il a dit dans son
cas il peut se prévaloir d'une baisse du
chômage déjà c'est pas si mal on
l'attendait depuis longtemps il a entamé
la réindustrialisation du pays mais
est-ce que ça suffira pas d'autres
problèmes sur lesquels le FN prospère
dans cette société je vous laisse un peu
réfléchir mais on n'est pas seulement
une émission là-dessus on est sur LCP on
a le droit de faire une pause on a le
droit de prendre un peu de recul alors
on va faire un recul de 40 ans enfin pas
exactement j'exagère 39 ans donc on est
en 1984 à la télévision comme
aujourd'hui c'est l'heure de vérité et
puis on pose la même question
qu'aujourd'hui c'était il y a 40 ans
mais comment faire pour faire reculer
l'extrême droite l'invité c'est le
premier ministre il a 38 ans on l'écoute
l'extrême droite
je pense que
l'extrême droite ce sont de fausses
réponses à de vraies questions
les questions sont vraies
c'est la question de la sécurité nous
avons parlé tout à l'heure c'est la
question de l'immigration donc c'était
il y a 40 ans et le Premier ministre de
la France estimait que deux vraies
questions posées par l'extrême droite
c'était l'immigration l'insécurité donc
je sais pas si vous avez prévu de parler
d'un sécurité ce soir mais pour ce qui
est de l'immigration bien on s'en occupe
au gouvernement je sais pas si vous avez
suivi mais Olivier Deran est parti au
Danemark qui est un pays où le droit un
reculer c'est à dire que la gauche a
pris des mesures très fermes contre
l'immigration donc d'une part elle s'est
maintenue au pouvoir au législatives ce
qui n'est pas le cas en France et
d'autre part l'extrême droite est passé
de 22 à 14%. donc elle n'a pas
totalement disparu bref je vais vous
laisser les battre évidemment mais je
vais reposer cette question qui date de
40 ans si le FN pose de fausses
questions à des vrais enfin de fausses
réponses à des vraies questions ce qu'on
cherche les bonnes réponses donc merci
merci pour ce billet particulièrement
salé ce soir j'ai commencé avec vous
François-Xavier Bourbon même si Stéphane
blackovski balaye un peu sur la forme
polémique quand même je voudrais qu'on
s'arrête sur la forme parce que c'est
pas rien on sait très bien que le
Conseil des ministres fuite chaque
mercredi Olivier fordy dans un Tweet
Comment le président
ose recadrer Elisabeth borne fille de
rescapés des camps parce qu'elle a
rappelé la filiation idéologique de
l'extrême droite s'il y a des
civilisations c'est celle du président
il y a beaucoup de réactions assez vives
notamment dans l'opposition mais mais
pas seulement pourquoi il fait ça comme
ça alors parce que vraisemblablement
Emmanuel Macron est très très agacé par
par Elisabeth borne et il fallait que ça
sorte là ça sort sur ses propos sur
Pétain la polémique prend une telle
ampleur parce que le Président de la
République fait un recadrage en conseil
des ministres et que ça sort du Conseil
des ministres sinon le les propos
d'Elisabeth borne on voit bien dans
l'interview qu'elle donne qu'elle
reprend la question du journaliste et
que c'est quelque chose c'est un
argument enfin c'est une rhétorique
habituelle en fait de renvoyer le
rassemblement national
parce que en fait Emmanuel Japon il est
aussi situation paradoxale il a eu une
intuition qui était une bonne intuition
en 2017 qui était la disparition ou la
transformation du traditionnelle clivage
droite-gauche en un clivage progressiste
conservateur pour européen eurosceptique
en s'appuyant sur cette idée là il se
retrouve au deuxième tour face à Marine
Le Pen il se retrouve au deuxième tour
en 2017 et en 2022 et entre ces deux
élections il y a aussi des élections
européennes ou le RN et le et à l'époque
c'était en marche se retrouve à
touche-touche très loin devant les
autres parties traditionnelles seulement
le problème c'est que ce faisant c'est
une analyse politique qu'il fait
stratégique qui l'applique et qui lui
apporte la victoire mais il installe le
rassemblement national dans la seule
force d'alternance et là Emmanuel Macron
ne pourra pas
représenter en 2027 et il pourra pas
combattre à nouveau Marine Le Pen donc
il y a un peu d'inquiétude qui monte
chez lui sur le sur le thème et il y a
bien falloir que quelqu'un là-bas donc
ça serait mon seul
héritage ce qui resterait et ça c'est ça
antise c'est ça c'est le modèle
Barack Obama Donald Trump il veut
surtout pas enfin il veut éviter ça à
tout prix mais il y a quand même une
part un peu d'humiliation non sur la
forme toujours mais on va venir sur le
fond Charles sapin on sait qu'elle est
sur la sellette est-ce que c'est une
manière de préparer les esprits avant
avant sa sortie tout à fait le président
de la République le sait très bien il en
est à son deuxième quinquennat tout ce
qui se dit en conseil des ministres
fuite potentiellement le fait d'ailleurs
très régulièrement c'est une façon pour
lui
d'une part de préparer l'opinion au
départ prochain d'Elisabeth borne d'un
remaniement qui va venir la question
n'est plus de savoir s'il va changer de
Premier ministre mais quand et de
l'autre de commencer aussi à envoyer des
messages à droite puisqu'on est dans une
séquence
discussion notamment avec la droite avec
des prochains textes qui arrivent
notamment de textes immigration alors
évidemment la droite n'est pas
majoritairement
le pénis mais une partie de l'électorat
de droite ne supporte pas c'est c'est
mis en cause morale et ces deux poids de
mesure ce traitement particulier qui
peut être qui peut être réservé au RN
donc c'est une humiliation qui a en plus
une saveur particulière si vous voulez
parce que
ces accusations morales et historiques
Emmanuel Macron lui-même ne s'en est
jamais jamais privé moi je vous rappelle
je me suis plongé un peu dans les
élections européennes c'était quelque
chose d'hypocrisie dans l'attaque
rappelez-vous Emmanuel Macron disait je
suis le rempart à la lèpre populiste il
mettait en cause des journalistes en
disant attention je vous trouve assez
assez gentil avec
totalement rien que pendant la
présidentielle il disait qu'on était
dans une période très très analogue à
l'entre-deux à ce qu'on a connu dans
l'entre-deux-guerres et qu'il trouvait
que les gens avaient oublié quel était
l'histoire et qui était l'extrême droite
donc si vous voulez c'est c'est une
double humiliation
il savait pertinemment que ça allait
savoir et en plus il fait un reproche de
quelque chose que lui-même a beaucoup
beaucoup usé ce débat sur la manière de
contrer le rassemblement national il est
très très vieux on l'a vu avec l'archive
de l'euro Fabius ce qui est nouveau en
revanche c'est que au fond il y a un
dilemme stratégique qui s'invite au
sommet de l'exécutif parce que des
différents entre le président et le
Premier ministre il y en a plein dans
l'histoire de la 5e mais de publicité
une division sur ça c'est nouveau quand
même Jean-Philippe Monet oui c'est vrai
c'est à la fois nouveau et problématique
parce que pour une raison simple au-delà
des circonstances politiques ont été
bien été rappelés la vérité historique
n'est pas séparable de la vérité tout
court et à un moment donné regardez
l'histoire en face n'est pas contraire à
regarder la réalité en face et donc dire
une réalité que le rassemblement
national exfn était fondé par des
miliciens collaborationnistes par les
Celtes c'était quand même pas
un petit bourgeois qui était
collaborationniste de salon il y en
avait beaucoup en France mais c'est
aussi dire c'est en cela que Isabelle
borne répondant à une question n'a fait
que dire une vérité historique c'est que
je pense que le en même temps doit
s'imposer pour le président de la
République Emmanuel Macron c'est que la
vérité historique et la vérité actuelle
sont conjointes on ne peut pas les
séparer mais on peut dire d'affiliation
pétaniste de ce parti et on peut aussi
le combattre sur le terrain des idées et
sur le fond ça n'est pas incompatible
mais il y a un sujet qui quand même qui
devrait être actuel c'est que sur le
sujet de Pétain on voit que le même
parti Marine Le Pen en premier
aujourd'hui et assez complaisant de voir
complice de dictateurs d'aujourd'hui
un tapis rouge sur dictateur
d'aujourd'hui donc ça devrait être assez
troublant et la commission parlementaire
en témoignent aujourd'hui avec le
désaccord le président absolument a un
peu revenu aujourd'hui pour en parler
avec Isabelle mais c'est un sujet actuel
la question de la filiation historique
n'empêche que pour les Français ça
semble assez loin quand on regarde
l'opinion qu'est-ce qui revient dans
l'image du rassemblement national
aujourd'hui c'est un parti comme les
autres ou encore une majorité de
Français considère que c'est un parti
d'extrême droite c'est un parti dont
l'image s'améliore et d'ailleurs les
résultats électoraux successifs sont là
pour le prouver mais qui une image qui
s'améliore mais plus lentement que l'on
peut le penser oui il y a des points
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé d'ailleurs
c'est un peu la victoire posthume de la
ligne Florent Philippot ce ne sont pas
les électeurs du rassemblement national
qui ont évolué mais c'est le
rassemblement national qui a su
renouveler une partie de son électorat
depuis que Marine Le Pen a pris le parti
elle n'a de 16 que de mettre en avant
les des thèmes sociaux
bien plus que l'obsession
immigrationnelle qui pouvait être celle
de de son père auparavant et surtout
elle a l'intelligence de rester neutre
et de ne pas trop prendre la parole sur
les sujets sociétaux parce que là elle
sait que le parti pourrait se fracturer
et aujourd'hui quand on l'a vu
d'ailleurs durant les campagnes pour la
présidentielle et pour les législatives
elle a énormément parlé de pouvoir
d'achat là aussi par des de fiscalité et
beaucoup moins de questions d'insécurité
d'immigration des items comme disent les
sondeurs nouveaux la crédibilité la
capacité à gouverner la compétence ça a
été longtemps des points faibles ça
n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui il y a
également la compréhension des
préoccupations des Français c'était un
parti totalement hors sol et donc elle a
évidemment progressé sur ces éléments en
revanche sur
un parti qui peut être encore qui
pourrait être encore un petit peu
dangereux soit raciste soit xénophobe il
y a toujours une majorité des Français
qui considèrent que le rassemblement
national n'est pas un parti communaute
c'est pour ça aussi que je pense que
Elizabeth borne la stratégie de
continuer dans la diabolisation n'est
pas une impasse il faut aller de pair
sur diabolisation et aussi et là c'est
plus la thèse la ligne Macron projet
contre projet et montrer l'incohérence
vous prenez le et en même temps
là-dessus je pense que l'affiliation
historique et le combat sur le fond sur
le programme sur l'opinion quand même à
Meaux marraine Le Pen quand même
deuxième personnalité après Édouard
Philippe j'ai regardé le baromètre Ipsos
43 pour Édouard Philippe 35 pour Marine
Le Pen c'est la deuxième effectivement
dans ce baromètre c'est pas la deuxième
personnalité politique préférée des
Français c'est la deuxième personnalité
la moins détestée des Français faut
revenir quand même à ça il y a en gros
un gros tiers des Français qui
aujourd'hui déclare avoir une bonne
image de de son action et c'est ce que
je reviens à ce que je disais sur les
thèmes sociaux le rassemblement national
a gagné la bataille de des milieux
populaires aujourd'hui quand vous
regardez à quoi ressemble comment se
structure les intentions de vote et même
les votes la réalité des votes notamment
à l'élection présidentielle les classes
populaires ont voté très largement au
second tour pour elle et beaucoup moins
pour Emmanuel Macron comme au premier
tour les personnes issues des milieux
ouvriers ou employés ont voté beaucoup
plus pour elle que pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon donc il y a eu un
renouvellement d'une partie de cette
électorale qui explique sa dynamique
électorale aujourd'hui mais j'insiste le
plafond de verre existe toujours il y a
toujours une majorité de Français qui
considère que ce parti n'est pas un
parti communiste très bien je vous fais
réagir dans un instant François
j'aimerais mais la preuve que ces
questions stratégiques sur le RN divise
au sein même du gouvernement et de la
majorité
Eric Dupont-Moretti s'était en 2022 à
l'été dernier en août
le point de détail de l'histoire du père
fondateur
les 17 ou 18 condamnations mais il est
vrai que la justice et laxiste
et puis où sont passés l'ousto ou son
passé lousto Châtillon pénins chorale
Dieudonné sa quenelle ou sont-ils caché
dans votre campagne électorale
Eric Dupont été qui répondait à une
question sur l'antisémitisme et qui
vivait très clairement le rassemblement
national là c'est pas du tout la ligne
Macron bratislavas et j'ose dire on est
vraiment sur la volonté du Front
républicain quel est votre regard à la
fois sur la polémique et sur ce qu'elle
révèle aussi d'une forme de difficulté à
contrer le RN vous savez j'ai vécu
quelques années au Danemark et quand on
vit dans un pays quand on l'observe on
comprend son propre pays aussi et j'ai
mesuré à quel point notre façon de faire
de la politique et les conditionner par
un regard
idéologique et historique là où les
Danois qui ont des politiques qui font
parler dans ce domaine là d'ailleurs
dans le domaine de l'immigration sont
pragmatiques j'ai compris la base que
voulait dire le pragmatisme c'est simple
c'est ça marche ça marche pas
Macron ça marche ça marche pas mais
c'est vrai
combien ça coûte c'est ça les débats
politiques chez nous c'est à quelle
famille idéologique ce sera tâche à
quelle est la filiation et la question
que ça m'inspire que m'inspire votre
débat c'est de savoir jusqu'où alors
évidemment nous nous aimons l'idéologie
nous aimons l'histoire ça fait partie
d'identité française
à quel moment jusqu'où l'histoire nous
guide-t-elle et à partir de quel moment
nous empêche-t-elle de penser le présent
le soir et l'idéologie
on observe quand même une petite
inflexion dans les dans les réformes en
tout cas dans les dans les messages les
annonces du gouvernement François-Xavier
Bourmeau le thème de la de la fraude
sociale portée par Gabriel Attal le
thème de l'immigration aussi on voit
bien qu'il y a une porte ouverte aux
républicains pourquoi pas sur l'aide
médicale d'État ce sont des thèmes qui
sont portés par le RN depuis toujours
qu'est-ce qu'il faut y comprendre il les
idées où ils proposent les bonnes
réponses aux vraies questions non alors
première chose la porte de sortie pour
Emmanuel Macron pour retrouver un peu de
un peu de calme elle est à droite la
porte de sortie c'est idéalement pour
lui un accord de coalition avec elle a
l'air et un accord de coalition avec
l'air vous le passez pas sur un plan
pour lutter contre la fraude la fraude
fiscale par exemple donc que ces thèmes
là soient portés en ce moment donc la
fraude sociale et l'immigration c'est
c'est on voit bien d'ailleurs dans le
projet loi immigration que il s'agit de
se mettre d'accord avec elle que les
négociations sont en cours c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça on peut revenir à
pétard là dessus sur la polémique Pétain
c'est il y a beaucoup dans les
propositions de LR de d'idées de
proposition qui était dans le programme
de Marine Le Pen si vous voulez vous
mettre d'accord avec elle a l'air et que
vous traitez les gars d'en face en gros
de pétainiste ça complique les ça
complique les négociations si voilà
c'est pour ça que le la flexion du
discours de d'Emmanuel Macron forcément
elle va un peu à droite parce que il va
pas passer d'accord avec la France
insoumise c'est impossible il reste plus
grand chose du Parti socialiste il y a
des micros groupes mais pas suffisamment
pour pour pouvoir espérer une atteindre
la majorité donc ça penche à droite et
mécaniquement dans une majorité qui est
construite en même temps à droite et à
gauche et bien la gauche ce rebiffe un
peu en fait ce sont des logiques
stratégiques politiques politicienne qui
explique aussi les positionnements du
jour Jean-Philippe Monet LR
d'aujourd'hui évidemment plus la droite
républicaine d'hier ou d'avant-hier et
ce qui reste de LR et c'est vrai et
marquée par une certaine porosité
idéologique je dis pas forcément de
complicité d'alliance qui jusqu'à
présent
ils ont dans l'ensemble refusé reprendre
les idées du RN pour le dire simplement
l'original à la copie sur l'aspect
porosité c'est que c'est vrai que la
droite républicaine était dir par des
Jacques Chirac Philippe Seguin à la
Juppé Nicolas Sarkozy compris qui était
d'une intransigence forte sur le
rapprochement en termes d'alliance avec
le parti d'extrême droite qu'il appelait
à l'époque comme ça un terme qu'on
entend plus beaucoup y compris chez
certains observateurs
ça veut pas dire que sur les idées ils
avaient pas une certaine dureté et qui
pouvait se débattre voir ce combattre
entre les différentes formations
républicaines simplement il y avait une
intransigence nette et cette netteté
c'est perdu avec le temps à la mesure du
rétrécissement au lavage de ce mouvement
politique qui est devenu LR qui m'a pas
fait 5% aux dernières élections donc ce
qu'il reste de LR c'est vrai que le
président penche vers sa droite pour
trouver une respiration politique et ça
c'est un état de fait et l'opinion
publique et au centre droit ou plutôt à
droite ça c'est toutes les études
d'opinion il voit que cette qui se
penchant là qui est le penchant français
pour autant complicité avec l'extrême
droite je pense que beaucoup de Français
sont majoritaires pour dire NON hier non
en 2017 en 2022 je pense qu'en 2027 ça
peut être réitérer on voit quand même
qu'il y a des reprises de propositions
sur le fond allez-y bien sûr
au contraire en fait la plupart des
sondages d'ailleurs c'est ça pose
question je parle sous votre contrôle
mais au sein de l'électorat LR il y a eu
beaucoup de moments où ils étaient en
faveur d'une union des droites
d'ailleurs ça pose différentes questions
mais en fait ce qui est intéressant
c'est ce débat vous avez raison de le
souligner c'est ce qui pose la question
c'est
quel argument opposé au RN et ce qu'il
faut continuer de le traiter
différemment des autres parties parce
que c'est vrai que quand on entend
pourquoi ça fait un petit peu le buzz et
quand on entend oui bon alors c'est
l'héritier de Philippe pétanque
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que pétanque
vient faire dans le débat je veux dire
ce n'est pas en corrélation avec les
attentes et les inquiétudes des Français
le fond le pouvoir d'achat
l'environnement évidemment cette musique
en tout cas ça fait pas revenir les
électeurs du RN vers d'autres parties
c'est sûr c'est une qu'on entend dire il
faut pas parler de l'histoire je suis en
train de rappeler les préoccupations des
Français vous me traiter des humour rien
là non mais j'entends dire cette forme
d'édulcoration
n'est pas une vérité historique ça c'est
sûr donc
c'est incroyable donc merci je vous en
prie donc c'est sur cette question de
donc quand on entend Philippe Pétain
c'est vrai que quand vous arrivez dans
un débat et que vous êtes sur la
réduction addite les room normalement
c'est c'est plutôt mauvais signe sur
votre argumentation et ce que souligne
Emmanuel Macron c'est que les réponses
doivent être faites sur le fond sur le
programme du RN et de prouver en fait le
côté qui
réalisable et peut crédible de ces
offres sur l'économie or pourquoi ces
attaques de fond on ne les entend pas
pour deux raisons déjà pour une raison
c'est une paresse intellectuelle c'est à
dire que pendant des années beaucoup se
sont reposés justement sur ces pointés
du doigt les filiation historiques et il
y a une autre raison et ça c'est une
vraie question qui est intéressante
c'est que beaucoup de formations
politiques et la macronie en tête on
refusait de répondre au fond au
rassemblement national parce que
répondre au fond au programme du
rassemblement national
et ce débat que ouvre Emmanuel Macron
voilà c'est intéressant comme débat et
c'est le risque de banaliser par les une
forme de technicisation du débat autour
de Marine Le Pen qui serait plus ou
moins bonne ou mauvaise sur par exemple
le taux de TVA est-ce qu'on attend de
l'extrême droite française j'ai compris
ces électeurs d'ailleurs qu'elle soit
performante sur les sujets liés à la TVA
ou à faire du marketing autour des chats
ce qui a été le cas pendant la même
chose mais il y a deux fois
on sait ce que vous attendez mais si
vous voulez
je pense qu'il y a multiple fronde de
débats et de confrontation avec le parti
d'extrême droite y compris sur les
sujets que vous évoquez ce qui sont
l'économie la compétence ou pas la
compétence la validité de ses
propositions mais ça doit pas faire
passer à la trappe certaines vérités
historiques
du président Macron de confondre
histoire et morale mais pas du tout
Emmanuel Macron
historique c'est pas un dieu plus
collectivement je vous propose de
regarder ce petit sujet de Maïté prénom
qui va dresser le bilan du groupe RN à
l'Assemblée 88 députés c'est quand même
une arrivée en force et pourtant à
arriver très très peu de réformes mais
même d'amendements adopter lors du bilan
regardez
87 députés du rassemblement national
puis le 19 juin les choses ont changé
que vous le vouliez ou non leur objectif
s'imposer en alternative crédible et
cela commence par la forme en séance
leur attitude se veut mesurer une image
de respectabilité pour casser celle du
parti historique cette quête de
normalisation s'accompagne d'une
stratégie sur le fond pour peser sur les
travaux parlementaires le rassemblement
national choisi de voter les amendements
ou les textes des autres partis en un an
il vaut donc les projets de loi du
gouvernement sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
la sécurité ou encore sur le nucléaire
en jeu de notre groupe c'était de
montrer qu'on était pas sectaire et que
quand un amendement arrivait sur la
table ont regardé pas d'où il venait on
regardait s'il améliorait ou pas ce
quotidien sur le pouvoir d'achat par
exemple beaucoup on a voté la prime pour
le pouvoir d'achat c'est pas la mesure
qu'on aurait voulu voir est-ce que ça
peut servir quelques Français oui donc
même si c'est pas parfait on
pourtant ces efforts ne payent pas en
retour au 16 mai sur les 1497
amendements discutés et en séance
publique 40 ont été adoptées le chiffre
et le plus faible de tous les groupes
parlementaires le Regis est quasi
systématique cette situation est
scandaleuse parce que
et elle démontre elle est très
révélatrice parce qu'elle demande quand
elle était le seul groupe que le pouvoir
dans toutes ses facettes
craint parce qu'il représente
l'alternance c'est le groupe du
Rassemblement national on n'a pas été
élu pour voter les propositions du
rassemblement du rassemblement national
j'allais dire c'est pas quelque chose de
très pensé c'est d'une certaine manière
dans notre façon d'être aucune alliance
ne semble donc possible avec les autres
groupes le rassemblement national reste
pour le moment un parti très isolé à
l'Assemblée nationale
voilà sujet simili m'a été Frémont
extrait du magazine de Clément Perrot
sur les 1 an du RN à l'Assemblée à
découvrir à la mi-juin sur sur LCP
François-Xavier Bourbon l'assemblée on
voit bien la stratégie de la Cava
cravate le sérieux la crédibilité calme
dans l'hémicycle contrairement aux
insoumis ça c'est un marche-pied pour
les échéances à venir pour Marine Le Pen
c'est en tout cas le Paris café quand
vous êtes le premier groupe d'opposition
vous occupez traditionnellement le
ministère de la parole c'est à dire que
vous allez brailler à la tribune le
problème pour le pour Marine Le Pen
c'est que le rôle est joué par les
insoumis donc ils sont arrivés à
l'Assemblée il fallait bien trouver une
place et se faire sa place il y avait
parallèlement à ce cette place à trouver
tout la dédiabolisation a poursuivre
donc ça a été les costumes les cravates
nous on s'habille bien pour se démarquer
de l'extrême gauche la France la France
insoumise et la tentative de
effectivement
à participer au débat public et surtout
apprendre
le bilan effectivement pour
rassemblement national et assez faible
mais sur ces 88 députés qui 89 députés
qui qui sont dans l'hémicycle 88
ils apprennent les codes de la vie
parlementaire et ça c'est quelque chose
qui
d’expérience et qui va
Marine Le Pen espère que ça va
fructifier avec l'encrage local en
circonscription qui va avec justement
tous les ministres qui se rendent dans
des circonscriptions tenues par des
députés du rassemblement national
témoignent tous de l'accueil républicain
qui est systématiquement fait et le
finalement de la tonalité très très
républicaine du comportement des élus du
rassemblement national sur l'image le
fait d'avoir un groupe pléthorique comme
ça des élus au contact sur le terrain là
aussi ça ripoline complètement le vieux
FN oui mais les éléments que vous
montrer dans votre portage sont aussi
très parlants oui d'accord il y a une
sorte de quête de respectabilité donc
d'une classe politique RN de cadre
assagi très bien qui reste toujours de
bons orateurs malgré tout je ne suis pas
certain que cette stratégie à long terme
soit forcément très payante je ne suis
pas certain notamment que les gens qui
ont voté pour les candidats RN aux
élections législatives ou pour Marine Le
Pen attendre ça de la part de leurs élus
on dit souvent dans tous les enquêtes
qu'on a pu réaliser nous d'autres ou des
enquêtes sociologiques à peu près un
tiers de la France qui se dit
aujourd'hui en colère c'est très souvent
les gens qui ont voté pour pour Marine
Le Pen ou pour des candidats d'urine
c'est pas forcément
des propositions concrètes et on en
arrive on pointe un deuxième point que
j'ai évoquait déjà tout à l'heure c'est
ce plafond de verre toujours et c'est ce
que l'on reproche au-delà de ces idées
au rassemblements nationales une sorte
de procès en incompétence d'une
incapacité à faire à faire des
propositions concrètes notamment dans le
domaine économique et toujours est-ce
qu'on le reprochait à ce qu'on déplorait
plutôt du côté de de Jean-Marie Le Pen
comme de sa fille ensuite c'est le fait
de ne pas être entouré en fait de ne pas
de n'avoir personne qu'est-ce qui se
passe si demain elle accède au pouvoir
est-ce qu'elle a de quoi avec qui
gouvernait parce que le cordon sanitaire
avec les autres parties et le reportage
le montrait bien malgré tout et toujours
là même s'il y a des porosités enfin la
droite pour l'instant reste très ferme
et ne cède pas ça c'est très important
toujours pas d'allier on le voit bien à
l'Assemblée nationale Marine Le Pen vote
et ses députés les censures des autres
dès qu'elle en dépose une c'est non et
donc il va y avoir ce problème et il est
absolument pas résolu aujourd'hui c'est
vrai en fait ce bilan de cette première
année de législation on peut le voir il
y a deux volets quoi il y a un premier
bilan qui a un bilan un peu froid
arithmétique où on voit que le
rassemblement national bien que premier
groupe d'opposition n'a emporté très peu
voire pas du tout de victoire
parlementaires aucune de ces
propositions de loi ont été adoptées
aucun de ces textes n'a réussi à
convaincre des députés en dehors de ces
rangs c'est pareil pour les amendements
et les seuls résultats qu'elle a eu
c'est en associant ses élus à des
initiatives qui n'étaient pas celles du
rassemblement national donc en effet le
cordon sanitaire est toujours là et on
le voit très clairement dans les muscles
en tout cas
maintenant si on s'arrêtait seulement là
on passerait à côté de quelque chose
parce que cette Assemblée nationale pour
Marine Le Pen lui offre aussi
[Musique]
parlementaires sur des ingérences
étrangères c'est une commission qui a
été voulue par le rassemblement national
et qui se retourne un peu en boomerang
contre elle puisque ça rapporteur
constance le grip et bien faites un
rapport qui très clairement parle
d'alignement du RN sur le discours russe
au moment de l'annexion illégal de la
Crimée en 2014 donc la normalisation
elle est pas encore complète en tout cas
pas à l'Assemblée nationale infinie pour
pour terminer combattre sur le fond et
rappeler l'origine c'est ça la bonne le
bonne équilibre
quand il s'agit de ceux qui veulent
s'opposer à la montée de l'extrême
droite en France et en Europe par
ailleurs mais je suis d'accord avec
Charles sapin sur un point c'est que en
fait autant de dire la France insoumise
a été un marche-pied pour Marine Le Pen
et le RN pour apparaître comme le
premier opposant c'est ce qui a apparu à
partir des outrances de la France
insoumise et qui a fait que ça
respectabilisé en creux pas grand chose
à dire la posture parlementaire des élus
du National
s'adresser pour autant aux électeurs de
Marine Le Pen
il y a une contradiction fondamentale
qui n'est pas résolue pour le
rassemblement national qui va être
l'enjeu des prochaines années c'est que
c'est un parti qui surf sur beaucoup de
peurs et sur le site l'anti-système donc
c'est le National populisme qu'on
connaît dans d'autres pays or la
respectabilisation la notabilisation du
rassemblement national et du le pénis
est en contradiction notamment vers
l'électorat populaire avec avec cela et
donc il faut qu'elle qu'elle reste
quelque part hors système tout en
essayant de gravir des échelons de la
crédibilité et loin sans faute c'est
pour aujourd'hui réussi merci on va
s'arrêter là merci pour ce décryptage et
à très vite j'espère sur LCP vous restez
avec moi François zimerais dans une
dizaine de minutes les parties prit de
nos affranchis ce soir Isabelle Lasserre
va revenir sur le mea Culp Emmanuel
Macron en Europe de l'Est le philosophe
Pierre auritavoyo va rendre hommage au
travail de la chercheuse au CNRS
Frédéric berger Belcaire menaçait de
mort après la publication de son livre
sur les Frères musulmans et puis dans
Bourbon Express cette proposition de loi
qui sauve de justesse les locataires
français mais d'abord on va revenir un
peu sur votre parcours et notamment sur
le procès Ramadan Françoise zimerais
vous défendiez donc celle qui a choisi
de se faire appeler Brigitte pour
préserver son anonymat votre cliente
apporter plein de pour viol contre
l'islamologue finalement acquitté le 24
mai dernier à Genève au terme d'un
procès que vous avez qualifié d'un digne
pour quelle raison on voit cela dans
l'invitation d'Hélène Bonduelle et on en
parle ensemble juste après
si on vous invite François zimerais
c'est parce que vous êtes furieux
furieux contre des juges que vous
qualifiez d'irrespectueux envers votre
cliente et furieux contre les
manipulations de l'accusé car dans le
processus de Tariq Ramadan qui vient
d'être acquitté par le tribunal de
Genève vous défendiez la plaignante qui
accuse l'islamologue de viol et
contraintes sexuelle au terme d'une
audience caricaturale
ou la dignité était absente
notre cliente n'a été ni entendu
ni respecté François zimmeret vous êtes
avocat vous avez notamment défendu
Carlos Ghosn lors de son incarcération
Japon et dénoncer des conditions de
détention moyenâgeuses voilà plus de 100
jours
qu'il est confiné dans une cellule
étroite
la lumière allumée de jour
comme de nuit
obligé de dormir sur le dos
le visage découvert
engagé en politique vous avez notamment
été ambassadeur de France au Danemark en
2015 vous échappez d'ailleurs de peu à
l'attentat islamiste qui vous vise vous
et un caricaturiste dans ce centre
culturel de Copenhague dans ces instants
réfléchit pas on réfléchit à
la situation on cherchait à l'analyser
et on se dit qu'on est en train de
revivre
ce que l'on a vu à Paris et que c'est la
fin
un drame qui vous pousse à écrire dans
ce livre j'ai vu partout le même visage
vous relatez vos rencontres quand vous
étiez ambassadeur itinérant chargé des
droits de l'homme vous donner la parole
à cette humanité blessée bâillonnée
alors nous avons une question à vous
poser François zimerais après tous ces
engagements politiques votre parcours
dans la diplomatie qu'est-ce qui vous
pousse à reprendre votre robe d'avocat
réponse à cette question pour commencer
je pense la liberté d'abord
la liberté puis la volonté d'apporter à
mon métier d'avocat qui est pas
simplement un métier mais qui est aussi
une façon de voir le monde et je pense
c'est un état je crois qu'on peut le
dire
d'apporter ce que toutes mes expériences
de vie m'ont appris alors on va y
revenir tout à l'heure
ambassadeur de François Danemark
ambassadeur des droits de l'homme
français mais je voudrais quand même
qu'on s'attarde sur ce sur ce procès
Ramadan l'islamologue a été donc
acquitté au bénéfice du doute vous
faites appel de la décision devant la
justice suisse tout comme le parquet
Suisse on l'a appris aujourd'hui en quoi
cette décision était injuste à vos yeux
je vais pas répondre à cette question
pardon parce que répondre à cette
question c'est aborder le fond du procès
c'est faire le procès sur un plateau ce
que je veux pas faire je pense que la
justice ne se rend pas sur les
télévisions je peux vous dire en quoi le
procès elle vous la contestez je la
conteste et j'assume tout à fait ce que
j'ai dit et ce que je défendrais
ni respecté alors en quoi précisément
les conditions c'est les conditions du
procès n'ont pas été respectées c'est le
bénéfice du doute c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut entendre ça fait partie des
droits de l'homme et même ma cliente
l'entend cela et c'est pour ça que c'est
quelqu'un de très respectable d'ailleurs
et qui ne mérite pas ce qu'on a dit
d'elle elle est c'est une personne
profondément respectable dont j'ai
découvert qui est digne et qui est
crédible mais encore une fois je vais
pas répondre aux je veux pas faire le
procès en l'absence de contradiction sur
un plateau de questions en revanche
elle-même était suffisamment
problématique pour qu'on en parle un peu
et d'ailleurs vos confrères qui étaient
là ont dénoncé y compris commencer par
vos confrères suisses qui ont considéré
que le procès méritait mieux que cela
oui je peux citer d'ailleurs l'éditorial
du temps qui écrit que c'était un procès
qui a été
très médiatisé étrangement c'est
l'attitude du tribunal sans doute
déstabilisée par la pression ambiante
qui a mis de l'huile sur le feu et nuit
à l'image de la justice en se montrant
notamment très peu respectueux de la
plaignante que s'est-il passé
les magistrats lui ont crié dessus non
je me souviens d'un épisode d'ailleurs
nous avons fait ce qu'on appelle un
incident à l'audience on l'a relevé
ou le président
a hurler silence à la plaignante qui
voulait ajouter quelque chose à sa
déclaration
et dire silence de cette façon là comme
tout dans la vie c'est la façon de faire
les choses dire silence crier silence à
une personne qui qui vivait dans ce
silence et sous la menace depuis 15 ans
c'était pas acceptable elle était
régulièrement coupée
on lui a posé des questions très très
crues ces avocats aussi d'ailleurs
sans délicatesse et encore une fois quoi
qu'on pense du fond et les juges ont le
droit d'avoir leur avis et nous nous si
nous contestons nous le contestons
devant la cour d'appel pas sur les
plateaux télévisions mais quoi qu'on
pense les personnes doivent être
respectées et considérés et je n'ai pas
eu ce sentiment là c'est la première
fois depuis que je fais ce métier que
j'ai ce sentiment et que je le dis aussi
clairement
et d'ailleurs tous ceux qui ont observé
cette audience
l'ont dit et ce sentiment est aussi
partagé par mes excellents confrères
Robert Hassel avocat suisse katellina de
la Sota Louise Dumas qui était avec moi
pendant l'audience les juges avaient
laissé on l'a laissé alors
c'est l'accusé c'est normal que l'accusé
par l'an dernier c'est normal qu'il
puisse déployer sa défense comme il
l'entend mais c'est normal aussi
lorsqu'on s'égare lorsqu'on s'en prend à
l'avocat de la plaignante ce qui était
le cas d'être recadré il ne l'a pas été
il est tellement à l'aise que à la fin
ça pas été relevé par les journalistes
mais moi c'est ma frappé un moment dans
sa déclaration finale il avait tout à
fait le droit de dire ce qu'il avait
envie il s'est adressé au tribunal en
disant cher tribunal comme on dirait
chers amis il était vraiment pas mal à
l'aise et mais bon le but d'un procès
n'est pas nécessairement de mettre à
l'aise ou de mettre mal à l'aise
l'accusé ou quiconque
l’irégalité de traitement
qui était extrêmement choquante et qui
nous a laissé un souvenir amer et qui
nous a déterminé aussi à faire appel à
lire les articles effectivement la
plaignante a dû dans le détail répondre
à des questions extrêmement crues sur la
chronologie les détails ont fait les
pénétrations et les violences les
questions crues
à ce type d'affaires la question
précisément parce que c'est des
questions crues qui touchent à
l'intimité qu'il faut les poser avec
tact et délicatesse et ça n'a pas été le
cas les Suisses donc les magistrations
du doute faute de preuve matérielles et
de témoins indirects Tariq Ramadan va
être également jugé dans quatre autres à
faire de viol en France il est accusé
par quatre femmes qui ont porté plainte
contre lui c'est sans doute pour ça
qu'il y avait beaucoup de journalistes
dans la salle du tribunal à Genève le
système judiciaire Suisse est-il
différent du système français oui il est
différent du système français parce que
en France on refait dans une procès
criminelle comme ça on refait toute
l'instruction à l'audience donc tout est
mis à plat et de façon totalement
contradictoire avec la défense qui peut
je jouer son rôle les avocats des
participes également
ensuite non les dossiers arrivent les
juges arrivent ils connaissent le
dossier
le dossier est avec eux ils l'ont étudié
et ils vont se concentrer que sur
certains points ça c'est la première
différence parce que c'est la conduite
audience c'est beaucoup moins spontanée
il y a beaucoup de choses qui n'ont pas
été dites ça veut pas dire qu'elles
n'ont pas été su qu'elles ne sont pas au
dossiers mais que la presse qui n'ont
pas été révélée publiquement parce
qu'elles sont supposées ensuite une
différence qui est majeure c'est que en
France c'est finalement c'est l'intime
conviction infinie qui va aider le
magistrat ou le jurer à trancher
dans un système dans le nouveau code
pénal suisse ou c'est l'absence de doute
raisonnable et donc ces critère
différent donc on demande pas au
magistrat quel est leur conviction leur
intime conviction mais savoir s'ils
peuvent si on suffisamment d'éléments
tangibles pour affirmer qu'il n'y a pas
la place pour un doute raisonnable alors
on va suivre évidemment l'appel en
Suisse et c'est ses affaires en France
vous êtes un homme viscéralement attaché
à la défense et notamment à la défense
des droits de l'Homme vous les avez
défendus au Cambodge comme jeûne avocat
mais après comment ambassadeur pour les
droits de l'homme entre 2008 et 2013 le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que les
droits de l'homme ils vont mal ils rend
Afghanistan Turquie Russie et j'en passe
vous avez l'impression que au fond
l'attachement à cette cause recule aussi
oui
c'est le sentiment que j'ai
il n'y a pas cette passion des droits de
l'homme que que j'avais connu quand
j'étais plus jeune
et j'ai vraiment le sentiment qu'on a
changé d'époque sur quelque chose de
fondamental et qui en particulier
l'universel
l'universel qui est au cœur de la
Déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme et laquelle la France est très
attachée qui est vraiment un apport très
important de la France
et c'est cette idée qu'il y a une
famille humaine et que du simple fait
que que nous sommes membres de la
famille humaine que nous sommes des
êtres humains nous sommes égaux en droit
et en dignité
le grand mouvement des droits de l'homme
ça a été de promouvoir par de là nos
différences on est tous différents de
sexe de de religion d'origine de tout on
est tous différents nous sommes
individus de mais de promouvoir ce que
nous avons en commun du simple fait que
nous appartenons jean-humain par-delà
ces différences ça a été le grand
mouvement et bien depuis quelques années
mais c'est le mouvement inverse on
assiste regardez la société regardez
autour de vous à la promotion générale
de la différence par de la les
similarités et c'est partout vous posez
le regard c'est la revendication
communautaire
identité d'une différence
quelque chose de une régression presque
tribalo ethnique là où on avait
construit l'idée d'un universel humain
donc ça c'est très préoccupant merci de
nous rappeler ce combat pour les droits
humains pour l'universalité des droits
de l'homme je suis sûr que les
chroniqueurs qui arrivent tout de suite
vont vous intéresser et notamment un
qu'on va accueillir tout de suite Pierre
Henry tavoyau notamment et également
Isabelle Lasserre et Stéphanie DESPER
les affranchis tout de suite pour leur
parti pris merci beaucoup François
zimeraient installer vous Isabelle
Lasserre correspondant diplomatique du
Figaro Pierrotte à boyaux président du
Collège des de philosophie bonsoir à
tous les deux on commence comme chaque
soir par Bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce
soir par Stéphanie des soir Stéphanie
bonsoir Myriam alors est-ce que parmi
vous certains sont locataires oui je
suis locataire et bien comme 40% des
Français sachez-le Myriam et vous avez
échappé de peu à une explosion à des
loyers par l'État dernier rappelez-vous
la loi pouvoir d'achat à plafonner les
augmentations à 3,5 % sauf que ce
bouclier sur les loyers se termine au 31
juin il a failli avoir un gros bug car
en pleine période d'inflation les
Français auront eu très mal alors
portefeuille car le gouvernement avait
légèrement oublié de s'occuper de la
prolongation de ce bouclier c'est ce que
dénonce l'opposition et c'est ce que
confirme hors caméra a des cadres de la
majorité qui peste contre le ministre du
Logement les députés Renaissance sont
donc venus à la rescousse du
gouvernement en dégainant en urgence une
proposition de loi la plus rapide peut
être de l'histoire parlementaire elle a
été déposée écoutez bien le 23 mai à
l'Assemblée étudié en commission mardi
30 et voter le lendemain c'est-à-dire
hier soir entre 23 heures et du matin ce
n'est plus une loi c'est un TGV mais
pour Thomas Cazenave l'auteur du texte
il n'y a pas de raté il faut voir le bon
côté des choses on est capable d'aller
très vite à l'Assemblée tout celles et
ceux qui disent qu'on a une assemblée
bloquée qui ne fonctionne pas voilà un
texte utile qu'on a réussi à examiner en
commission dans l'hémicycle avec un vote
largement majorité qui va être examiné
la semaine prochaine par le Sénat et moi
je trouve que ça montre au contraire
qu'on est capable de travailler vite
bien avec le gouvernement ici à
l'Assemblée avec avec le Sénat
alors sans cette loi Express Myriam les
loyers aurait augmenté d'au moins 6% des
Juifs effectivement il y avait le feu au
lac
j'imagine que tout le monde a voté pour
ce texte rapidement Myriam ce serait
trop simple la proposition de loi pardon
était largement adoptée avec 259 voix
mais la gauche a voté contre pourquoi et
bien parce que Carla nupes estime que la
hausse sera encore trop importante en
cette période d'inflation pour les
locataires
après la hausse de trois et demi pour
son l'an dernier
proposer une nouvelle hausse de trois et
demi pour cent cette année c'est-à-dire
plus de 7% sur deux ans pour pour les
locataires de ce pays ça me semble tout
à fait démesuré pas du tout équilibré et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
voté contre et que nous avons proposé un
gel déloyé alors la loi sera au Sénat de
la semaine prochaine la majorité espère
la voté définitivement la semaine du 20
juin les loyers seront à leur encadrés
jusqu'à fin mars 2024 et si le
gouvernement veut à nouveau prolonger
cet encadrement il faudra que le
ministre du Logement fasse une grosse
croix sur son agenda merci beaucoup
Stéphanie c'est sûr qu'en pleine crise
de logement une hausse aurait été pour
le moins mal venue alors on va parler
d'un livre ce soir avec vous
Pierre-Henri tavoyau vous vouliez
revenir sur l'ouvrage de Florence berge
au blackaire le frérisme et ses réseaux
c'est c'est Odile Jacob on en a beaucoup
parlé notamment quand la Sorbonne a
décidé de suspendre la conférence
qu'elle devait y prononcer oui alors je
suis organisateur de cette conférence
donc je vais pas de publicité ici parce
que de toute façon les instructions les
inscriptions sont closes mais je
voudrais revenir sur le fond du du livre
qui est un livre qui est intéressant
Laurence berger blacker est une
anthropologue chargé de recherche au
CNRS elle a été connue pour ses travaux
sur le halal voilà vraiment tout à fait
passionnant et en effet à l'occasion de
son dernier ouvrage elle a fait l'objet
de menaces et laisse actuellement sous
protection policière et pour vous c'est
un livre important et courageux oui
c'est un livre alors important et
courageux vraiment important parce que
il essaye d'aborder de façon globale un
phénomène qui rassemble à la fois des
grands intellectuels les grands penseurs
el Bana fondateur des Frères musulmans
mais aussi des influenceurs des
activistes comme Tariq Ramadan dont vous
avez parlé et puis tout un réseau de
d'organisation qui est présent sur le
territoire occidental et en fait le
grand défi de Florence Berger Blanc
c'est vraiment de d'unifier ça en
essayant de construire le phénomène et
de dire qu'il y a deux éléments
essentiels d'abord un objectif qui est
un objectif qui est très simple à
formuler il faut instaurer le califat
mondial l'État islamique universel et
ceci non pas seulement dans les États
musulmans mais aussi dans les pays
occidentaux ça c'est le premier point et
puis ensuite une méthode et une
stratégie qui est distingue du
djihadisme qui est violent du salafisme
qui est plutôt une logique de repli sur
la pureté musulmane mais une stratégie
d'influence il y a trois armes
l’influence l'entrisme il y a aussi la
défense et la diffusion d'une
orthopraxie le voile le halal qui permet
de manifester une identité vindicative
et puis ostensible et puis aussi
troisième élément armes décisive la
dénonciation de l'islamophobie mais
c'est sur ce dernier point que la
diffusion l'idéologie des Frères
musulmans est la plus importante oui
c'est ça qui est très intéressant parce
que l'islamophobie c'est un conseil
extrêmement confus le spectre est très
large ça va de la moindre critique que
l'on peut faire à l'égard de l'islam
jusqu'à en effet ça c'est tout à fait
légitime
un pays démocratique jusqu'à c'est puni
par la loi l'appel à la haine raciale
quasiment à l'égard des musulmans et ça
c'est évidemment proscrit donc sous cet
appellation d'islamophobie on peut
ratisser large et de fait il y a deux
mouvements qui se rallient en quelque
sorte à cette orientation du côté de la
gauche ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
l'islamo-gauchisme ce terme contreversé
mais qui consiste à dire que les
islamistes en fait peuvent être très
utiles dans la contestation radicale de
du capitalisme né au colonial à l'égard
du Grand Sud et puis de l'autre côté et
bien ce qu'on peut appeler le
libéralisme ou le néolibéralisme wok qui
considère que ça peut être très utile
islamiste pour lutter contre toutes ces
minorités opprimées qu'il faut défendre
et qu'il faut reconnaître et contre cet
état républicain laïque qui est
absolument abominable et ça crée des
bizarres qu'on entend par exemple il y a
un féminisme islamiste alors mon voile
mon choix on sait bien que c'est pas
quand même la caractéristique principale
il y a un anti impérialisme islamisme
alors que même que on voit que c'est
conquérant il y a même un antiracisme
islamiste alors même que l'antisémitisme
est quand même assez présent donc c'est
des éléments très importants ce livre
sur le fond il fait débat ce livre il
fait davantage polémique que débat parce
que on lui reproche aux trois choses
l'islamophobie mais évidemment vient de
voir ce que c'est assez problématiques
le complotisme et puis aussi ce manque
de rigueur scientifique alors sur ces
trois points je crois qu'il faut
vraiment être clair c'est critiques sont
totalement infondées il y a pas de
complotisme parce que Florence berger
Belcaire s'expose à la critique elle se
protège pas contre la critique mais elle
présente des éléments de taper et puis
il y a une richesse informelle tout à
fait considérable et donc cette critique
et bien on l'attend toujours et c'est
plutôt dans la dénonciation que dans la
critique que le débat pour le moment
fait merci en voilà un parti pris voilà
d'un tout petit mot vous voyez je
sentais que vous avez envie de réagir il
faut la défendre cette chercheuse
ce qu'elle fait est très courageux et il
faut les défendre et c'est quand même
voyez c'est en écho à ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure le fait qu'aujourd'hui
soit si difficile de s'exprimer
et que il y a un partie de censure aussi
général c'est un marqueur du recul des
droits de l'homme que nous disons sur
tout à l'heure
correspondance avec cette chronique
allez Isabelle il nous reste peu de
temps mais vous allez nous parler quand
même de ce voyage en Moldavie et en
Slovaquie d'Emmanuel Macron qui a tenté
de reprendre le leadership en Europe
peut-il y arriver après tout ce qu'il a
dit alors il est un petit peu trop tôt
pour le dire tant le passif en fait
entre Emmanuel Macron et les pays
d'Europe centrale et d'Europe orientale
était importante tous ces pays qui pour
la plupart ont vécu l'occupation
soviétique dans leur chair dans leur
sang et qui redoutent en fait d'être des
prochaines cibles sur la liste de
Vladimir Poutine en fait n'ont pas
apprécié toutes les petites phrases qui
ont émaillées le quinquennat de Lake
quinquennat de l'Emmanuel Macron quand
il a dit il ne faut pas humilier la
Russie quand il a dit il faut offrir des
garanties de sécurité à la Russie en
pleine guerre en Ukraine vous rendez
vous compte et puis aussi tous les coups
de téléphone qu'il a donné à Vladimir
Poutine et qui n'ont donné aucun
résultat et qui sait au cœur de votre
et là incroyable un mea culpa d'Emmanuel
Macron qui dit au pays de l'Est nous
avons perdu une occasion de vous écouter
alors il ne fait pas une Emmanuel Macron
ne se déduit jamais là il a un peu tout
mis sur le dos de Shakira qui en 2003
avait traité les pays d'Europe orientale
de un conséquent léger qui leur avait
dit vous avez perdu une manière de vous
thermer en gros il leur a dit j'ai
compris je vous ai je vais vous écouter
le début d'un c'est ça qui va permettre
possiblement un réengagement de la
France en Europe de l'Est par ailleurs
il a aussi réaffirmé un soutien très
fort de la France à l'Ukraine il a
éclairci son discours c'est à dire que
la paix aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron a eu
du mal à dire pendant longtemps il a eu
du mal à dire l'Ukraine doit gagner mais
sans vraiment que la Russie perdre
aujourd'hui c'est très clair la paix
doit être aux conditions de l'Ukraine
elle ne doit pas se les territoires ne
doivent pas se négocier et surtout pas
de cesser le feu donc pas de zone grise
au cœur de l'Europe
les paroles aux actes sur la Moldavie il
a réussi à convaincre la Moldavie aussi
là il fallait dire à tous ces pays qui
veulent rentrer dans dans l'Europe que
ce n'est pas un lot de consolation et
que tout ça va se faire progressivement
et aussi rassurer la France sera
toujours là pour aider les pays du flan
est mais alors ce qui est très compliqué
c'est que fait-on avec les Balkans
occidentaux qui sont une zone grise de
facto aujourd'hui au cœur de l'Europe et
en pleine conférence de la CPE la
communauté politique européenne en
Moldavie on a vu le Kosovo à nouveau
s'enflammer ce qui prouve que la
question n'est pas du tout réglée et là
les Européens n'ont pas encore de
véritables solutions
auprès de Macron Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui et beaucoup plus qu'il ne
l'était avant pour une entrée à moyen
terme de l'Ukraine dans l'OTAN sans
doute plus que Joe Biden c'est Emmanuel
Macron qui a étalé apporter la
candidature de l'Union européenne à
volodymire Zelinski donc effectivement
ça avance mais voilà le début d'une
autocritique avec des résultats qui sait
tout peut arriver en espérant que
l'administration américaine tiendra
longtemps parce que l'aide à l'Ukraine
elle tient quand même sur les États-Unis
merci et merci pour la concision merci
Isabelle Lasserre Pierre-Henri tavoyau à
très vite Stéphanie Despierre on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine et Merci à
VOUS François d'imeray on reparlera de
l'appel et puis peut-être d'autres
d'autres procès d'autres dossiers à
venir c'est la fin de cette émission
demain vous retrouvez Clément merico
manette à la semaine prochaine très
belle soirée sur LCP
[Musique]